- Just live in the
fucking present, guys.
(laughing)
(hip hop music)
I just think the best form
of revenge is a good body,
so like, fuck everyone.
- Oh!
Like clapping, alright, I see.
- Yeah, just look good.
- Just be more amazing.
- Yes!
- I'll be like,
I'd be more amazing
to clap back, yeah.
- At all times.
(laughing)
Nowadays with social media
it's way more intense.
I really love the whole blocking thing
on Instagram these days,
and I am using it every second, I love it.
I love to take social media breaks.
Like I'll post things and
try not to read the comments.
'Cause if I was posting
something about me,
I post something with me raising
money for cancer awareness
and I got reamed for it.
So it's like no matter what I do,
you're gonna have, just haters.
So just know that that's
the way of the world,
and just love yourself.
- I'm an all in person.
It's like just get out.
- Honestly, if you're not all in,
I just feel like you're not,
like you just don't care.
- Yeah.
Why bother?
- 'Cause I've been in
relationships that I wasn't all in
and I was like, I'm just
trying to be discreet,
and really I actually didn't like you.
- Yeah, stop being so shady. (laughs)
- So I was fuckin' shady.
There's 24 hours in a day.
I gotta do it and figure it out.
But the last week I've been really bad.
(giggling)
But I chose a nightclub over the gym,
and I'm kinda still doing cardio dancing.
So, you know.
Fuck you, bitch.
(laughing)
I hate when people say, are you tired?
Suck my dick.
That's so rude.
(laughing)
That really is.
- I feel like--
- Are you a food sharer?
- I am a food sharer.
- Me, too, I'm very sharey.
In fact, I like multiple appetizers.
- Oh my god, I order, I
would rather order 12 things
and just have a bite of everything.
- Me, too.
- And more is better than less.
I don't wanna be hungry.
I love food.
So don't--
- More is more.
- Yeah, more is more.
Don't fuck with my food,
but I'll share with you.
But we're all gonna dig in.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You just YOLO, you only live once.
You can't worry about it.
- Yeah, I agree.
- We all look like idiots.
Have you ever seen Seinfeld?
(laughing)
Where like Elaine?
You just gotta be Elaine
and don't care.
- Oh, I love Elaine.
- You can't care.
- Amazing.
No, you just go big.
- Balls to the walls.
I try to not bring baggage.
I really think I'm
great at having closure.
I'm living in the present.
I can't dwell on the past.
And if I do, I'm not ready
to be in a new relationship.
So I try to really know
that I'm healed and then,
'cause it's not fair.
It's not fair to yourself or
to the person you're dating.
God, take some shots
and just figure it out.
We're all about to throw
in the towel, I feel like.
(laughing)
Just that's life.
And take a fuckin' bubble bath after that.